Game of Thrones Season 6 Episode 10, the season
finale – let’s have a look.
We begin in King’s Landing with Cersei and
Tommen and Margaery and the Sparrow suiting
up for the big trial, with sept bells tolling
in the background, an ominous calm before
the storm.
Everyone comes to the Sept – the sparrows,
the Tyrells, Lancel and Kevan Lannister, the
lords and ladies of King’s Landing, though
suspiciously, Cersei and Tommen stay at the
Red Keep.
The trial begins, and Loras submits to the
Faith, confesses his crimes of banging Renly,
and lying about it at trial, and as punishment,
he has to give up the Tyrell name, which pretty
much ends House Tyrell, cause while in the
books, Loras has brothers, the show-version
of Loras is apparently the only heir to their
house.
The Sparrow’s goals aren’t just religious,
they’re political, he’s taking down the
great houses, so now that Tyrell’s gone,
he turns to Lannister, sending Lancel to go
get Cersei.
Lancel, for some reason, decides to follow
a boy into a basement, where he gets stabbed
and discovers the wildfire set to blow up
the Sept.
Meanwhile, Pycelle is lured to Qyburn’s
laboratory where he’s killed by little birds.
In the books, it’s not Qyburn, but Varys
who does this – Varys murders Pycelle and
Kevan and gives this cool speech about how
he’s working to destabilise Westeros, to
make the Targaryen invasion easier – though
in the books he’s sorta supporting a different
Targaryen – it’s complicated – but the
point is that now Pycelle is dead.
Back at the Sept, Marge suspects that something’s
up, so she tries to evacuate, but it’s too
late.
Lancel tries to stop the wildfire but he’s
too slow too, so everything blows the fuck
up, killing the Sparrow, in his moment of
victory, and the Tyrells, in their moment
of defeat, killing Cersei’s own uncle, Kevan
Lannister and his son Lancel.
And all these hundreds or thousands of others,
ladies and lords, sparrows, smallfolk, everyone
in and around the Sept is killed by Cersei.
How can she justify this terrible crime?
In the next scene, we see Cersei with Unella,
the shame bell lady, and Cersei says the reason
she killed all these people is “because
it felt good”, that imagining their shock
and pain is the greatest joy she’s ever
felt.
This is some Ramsay Bolton level evil here.
Previously when Cersei did terrible things,
she’d tell herself that the she did it to
protect her kids, but here she’s straight
up saying that she kills people for pleasure,
she’s turned to the Dark Side, and the Mountain
is the Darth Vader to her Emperor – she
sends him in torture Unella, and we get a
brief shot of the Mountain unmasked.
It’s hard to see in the dark, but Gregor
does pretty much look like Vader.
Then we see Tommen, watching his city burn.
He has a failed as a king by letting his people
die.
He has failed as a husband by letting his
wife Margaery burn.
He has failed as a follower of the Faith by
letting the Sparrow blow up.
And of course none of this is really his fault.
He’s always been a pawn of other players,
manipulated by the Sparrow, by Cersei, by
Margaery, he’s never really done anything
of his own will before, so this death is tragic
not only because he was basically a good kid,
and that he never knew his real father, and
that his family mistreated him, its tragic
that deciding to die is like the first real
choice he’s ever made.
The joke going round at the moment is that
this why they call it King’s Landing, cause
you know, the King landed…
All this stuff, by the way, will be very different
in the books.
For starters the Tommen of the books is like
ten years old, his main activities are to
play with his kittens, and to try to outlaw
beets – book-Tommen won’t be jumping outta
windows any time soon.
The way it might go down in the books is that
Tommen might die some other way, then Cersei
will blow up the wildfire in response, in
grief and rage.
Further, the wildfire in the books probably
won’t just blow up the Sept, in fact the
wildfire beneath the Sept was found and removed,
but there still is wildfire “all over the
city” – so maybe it’ll be the whole
city that burns down.
This may happen in the show too, somehow,
because we still have that vision of the Red
Keep burned that hasn’t happened yet – maybe
it’ll be Dany’s dragonfire that sets it
off.
Anyway.
Over at the Twins, the Freys and Lannisters
celebrate the retaking of Riverrun.
Jaime and Bronn chat, and then Walder comes
along and says he and Jaime aren’t so different,
you and I – they’re both Kingslayers – Walder
killed King Robb Stark at the Red Wedding,
and Jaime killed King Aerys Targaryen, during
Robert’s Rebellion twenty years ago.
Both Walder and Jaime are hated for these
dishonourable killings, though what Walder
doesn’t know is that Jaime killed the Mad
King for a good reason, to stop Aerys blowing
up King’s Landing with wildfire – bit
like what Cersei just did.
Jaime doesn’t want to be like Walder.
He increasingly tries to be a good, honourable
person – so it’ll be interesting to see
how he reacts to Cersei’s wildfire attack.
Cersei sees the dead body of her last son.
And it’s just like the gypsy woman said
– Maggy the Frog prophesied that all Cersei’s
children would die – gold their crowns,
and gold their shrouds, and it all came true.
So maybe the reason Cersei takes the death
of her son so calmly is that she already knew
it was going to happen, she’d already grieved
and now she’s numb, empty, with nothing
left in the world to give her joy, except
the suffering of her enemies.
Another part of the prophecy in the books
is that Cersei will be replaced by a “younger
and more beautiful queen” – Cersei thought
this was Margaery, but it’s probably gonna
be Dany.
In the Reach, Sam and Gilly arrive at the
city of Oldtown, that lighthouse there is
called the Hightower, they’re not creative
with names here.
They go to the Citadel, home of the maesters,
they deal with some annoying bureaucrat, and
then Sam’s let into the library.
Reading is one of Sam’s few loves, and this
is the biggest library in Westeros, maybe
in the world, so this is a dream come true
for Samwell Tarly.
Of course it’ll also be important to the
plot – maybe Sam will find some book about
white walkers or Azor Ahai or Valyrian steel,
something that could help the humans win the
war gainst the walkers.
Also that astrolabey thing at the ceiling
is the thing from the intro of the show, showing
the history of Westeros.
But yeah while Sam is reading, it’s not
clear what Gilly and her baby will do, because
the Citadel doesn’t accept women and children.
In the books, there’s heaps of other stuff
going down here, like, the Faceless Man Jaqen
H’ghar comes disguised as an alchemist to
steal a book, and one of the Sand Snakes comes
disguised as a man to study, and later ironborn
raiders under Euron arrive, and there’s
also this enigmatic maester called Marywn
the Mage doing some spooky magic stuff, he
might be the archmaester this guy mentions.
So we don’t know how much of this will make
into the show, but there’s certainly lots
of cool content to draw from the books.
One likely conflict in the show is that Sam’s
father Randyll may come for his Valyrian steel
sword Heartsbane, which we see Sam still has.
Up at Winterfell, Jon complains to Mel about
having to sit at the back at family feasts.
Mel tells him to check his privilege – she
grew up as a slave, at least in the books
– she’s still haunted by nightmares of
her childhood – and her original name, by
the way, was Melony.
Then Davos arrives and confronts Mel about
the murder of Shireen.
Mel admits that she did it, admits she was
wrong, but argues that Jon should keep her
anyway cause she’ll be useful in the war
against the walkers.
Which is a really good point – Mel is one
of the only people who seems to know what
the deal is with the war for the dawn and
Azor Ahai and all that, but regardless, Jon
decides to exile Mel, orders her to “ride
south”.
Which could go in some interesting ways – at
the same time Mel heads south, the brotherhood
without banners is heading north – Thoros
is a red priest, like Mel, and in the show
they’ve met before.
Maybe they’ll catch up, talk about their
god, and Jon’s resurrection and stuff.
Brienne and Pod are also heading north, and
they get caught up with the brotherhood in
the books.
Arya’s also around – when Mel meets her
in Season 3, she says they’ll meet again.
So all of these characters could be somehow
involved in whatever comes next for Melisandre.
Jon and Sansa talk, and she apologises for
not telling Jon about the knights of the Vale
before the Battle of the Bastards.
She doesn’t explain why she didn’t tell
him – even though it was kind of a big deal
strategically – but he accepts her apology
– of course, he should be apologising too
– he almost got everyone killed by riding
into the middle of battle instead of sticking
to the plan with the trenches, so really both
Sansa and Jon were pretty dumb last episode.
The point of this scene, though, seems to
be to show some tension and uneasiness between
Jon and Sansa – it’s not certain if they’ll
trust each other – which could lead to conflict
next season.
Also, a white raven arrives to signify that
winter has officially finally come – and
it only took six seasons.
Olenna Tyrell comes to Dorne.
She wants revenge on Cersei for killing her
family, so she allies with the Sand Snakes,
who also hate the Lannisters for the deaths
of Oberyn and Elia.
Then Varys walks in, representing Daenerys,
and they form a powerful three way alliance
between Targaryen, Tyrell and Martell.
Of course the Sand Snakes aren’t really
Martells, they’re illegitimate bastards
who murdered the rightful Lord Doran Martell.
And Olenna isn’t really a Tyrell, she’s
a Redwyne who married a Tyrell, so she probably
shouldn’t be in power either.
The politics here don’t really strictly
make sense, but the overall idea of this alliance
is cool and sets the stage for Daenerys to
invade.
In Meereen, Daenerys breaks up with Daario.
She can’t bring a lover to Westeros, because
politically, she needs to open for marriage.
Daario is to stay and keep the peace in Meereen,
which seems like a bad idea.
Daario’s a random mercenary.
He doesn’t know how to govern, and he doesn’t
care about Meereen.
And the situation here is still far from okay,
right?
Dany has banned slavery and cast down the
masters, but there’s no new system to take
its place.
The Sons of the Harpy are still out there,
and the freed slaves still need protection.
But Daenerys decides to declare Mission Accomplished
and roll on out anyway.
She renames Slaver’s Bay to the Bay of Dragons,
which is cool, but you could call North Korea
Freedom Land, and that wouldn’t make it
true.
Conquering a foreign land, destroying the
existing social structure, then leaving, can
have very bad results.
One of the major themes of the books is the
messiness and moral complexity of war, and
for the show to capture this, it should revisit
Meereen later to show us the chaos Dany’s
leaving behind her.
On a lighter note, who are the eligible bachelors
of Westeros Dany might marry?
Maybe Jaime – now that he’s been released
from his Kingsguard vows, he’s presumably
the heir to House Lannister and all its power,
and Jaime might not be keen on Cersei now
that she’s a mass murderer and all – so
maybe Dany’ll hook up with Goldenhand – only
catch might be that he killed her dad.
A better candidate could be Jon – as the
King in the North, he controls a huge chunk
of Westeros.
He’s also supposedly Azor Ahai, the prophesied
saviour of the world, just as she is, and
he kinda represents Ice, in the same way Dany
represents Fire and the books series is called
A Song of Ice and Fire, so basically Jon and
Dany could make a hell of a power couple.
The only reason why it probably won’t happen
is that it almost feels too obvious.
Dany talks with Tyrion, and he swears himself
to her service, seems truly devoted to her
cause.
Which seems kinda sudden, almost out of character
– Tyrion’s hardly the kneeling type, and
in the books he’s cynical about this whole
Targaryen restoration business.
But it does kinda make sense that he’d be
drawn to Dany.
Tyrion’s just lost his family, and his lover,
he’s far from home, what he needs now is
purpose.
And back in Westeros, that was politics.
Being Hand of the King made him feel valuable
and important, so when Daenerys makes him
her Hand, that’s exactly what Tyrion needs.
Same goes for a lot of Dany’s followers.
She draws all these misfits and exiles and
broken men to her, people who need a flag
to follow, something to believe in.
She offers them hope for a brighter future,
so they fight for her.
And historically, that’s never gone badly,
right?
Then we see Arya infiltrate the Twins disguised
with the face of a serving girl.
She makes a pie out of Black Walder and Lothar
Frey, and feeds it to their father, Walder
who she then kills to avenge the deaths of
her mother and brother at the Red Wedding.
Fans have pointed out that the three men who
arranged the Red Wedding – Walder Frey,
Tywin Lannister, and Roose Bolton – are
killed in the same way their victims are – Walder
has his throat slashed, like Catelyn, Tywin
is shot with a crossbow, like Robb, and Roose
is stabbed in the gut, just like Talisa, so
there’s a cool symmetry there.
But yeah Arya has made another kill, she watches
and smiles as the man before her dies, and
it’ll be interesting to see how the show
plays Arya’s arc in the future.
Like, are we meant to cheer as this child
dedicates her life to a murder spree?
Or should we question whether violent vengeance
is the only answer?
But for now, there are still targets left
on Arya’s list – she’s killed Polliver,
Meryn Trant, and now Walder Frey, but there’s
still Cersei and Gregor Clegane, so maybe
Arya’ll go after them.
But there were others who were on her list
temporarily – the Hound, for killing Mycah,
Beric and Thoros and Melisandre for betraying
Gendry – and all these guys are currently
in and around the riverlands – so maybe
something’ll happen with them.
Back at Winterfell, Sansa meets with Littlefinger,
in the same spot Ned and Cat meet in Season
1.
Littlefinger says that his ultimate goal is
become the King of Westeros, with Sansa at
his side.
Which pretty much fits with what we’ve seen
of him so far – he’s always been hungry
for power, and he’s always wanted Sansa
– mostly cause she reminds him of her mum,
who Littlefinger loved.
But Sansa rejects him – she knows that he’s
only really out for himself – but she also
doesn’t move against him which she probably
could and should.
Cause Littlefinger’s a seriously bad dude,
right?
He killed Sansa’s aunt Lysa.
He betrayed Ned Stark.
He caused the War of the Five Kings by turning
the Lannisters against the Starks.
He even helped kill King Joffrey for what
that’s worth.
Littlefinger is dangerous and he’s worked
against the Starks.
And as the Lady of Winterfell, Sansa’s in
a position to take him down.
She could tell the knights of the Vale that
Littlefinger killed their Lady Lysa, and lied
about the Boltons.
She could tell the lords of the north that
Littlefinger betrayed their Lord Ned Stark,
though we don’t know how much Sansa knows
about that.
Either way, Sansa totally could get Littlefinger
imprisoned or executed for his crimes which
would make everybody much safer, but she doesn’t
– she lets him go.
So, while Sansa doesn’t team up with Littlefinger
here, she’s leaves that door open, keeps
him as possible ally in the future – which
could be really useful, but could also go
very badly, cause as Sansa says herself, only
a fool would trust Littlefinger.
Beyond the Wall, Benjen drops off Bran and
Meera by a weirwood tree – the same tree
Jon and Sam swear their Night’s Watch vows
at in Season 1.
Benjen says he can’t take them through the
Wall itself, because the Wall has magic that
stops zombies like him from going through
– which is the same deal as the book character
Coldhands.
The worrying thing is that these spells that
protect the Wall are probably the magic of
the children of the forest – the same kinda
magic that protected Bloodraven’s cave until
that magic was broken by the Night King’s
psychic connection to Bran, and that mark
he made in Episode 5.
Maybe the magic of the Wall could be broken
in some similar way.
So anyway Benjen leaves, says he’ll do what
he can to fight the white walkers, and Bran
turns to the weirwood tree, says that’s
he’s the three-eyed raven now – and again
we still don’t really know what that means
exactly, but it involves these visions he
has through the weirwood trees.
And then we get one of the most anticipated
moments in the series – Bran has a vision
of the birth of Jon Snow.
We see young Ned Stark at the Tower of Joy,
seeing his sister Lyanna in a “bed of blood”,
just having given birth to Jon.
This finally proves that Jon is not the bastard
son of Ned and some unknown woman, but is
actually the son of his sister Lyanna.
Now, the episode doesn’t make clear who
the father is, but we know from hints in the
books and the show, and from a frankly confusing
graph from HBO, that the father of Jon Snow
is Rhaegar Targaryen.
Rhaegar hasn’t appeared in the show, but
basically, he’s the older brother of Daenerys,
and the son of the Mad King Aerys.
Some twenty years before the story starts,
Rhaegar ran off with Lyanna Stark, and this
started Robert’s Rebellion, the war that
killed Aerys and Rhaegar and made Robert the
King of Westeros.
Robert hated Targaryens, he wanted to kill
them all, and that’s why Jon had to be hidden
– as the son of Rhaegar, Jon is half-Targaryen,
so Ned had to lie and say Jon was his bastard,
in order to protect him from Robert, that’s
what Lyanna is talking bout here –
But yeah the point of all this is that Jon
is the son of a Stark and a Targaryen, of
ice and fire.
He’s the grandson of the Mad King, and the
nephew of Daenerys – which makes this potential
hookup kind of awkward.
But this could have some huge implications
– this means that Jon could have a claim
on the Iron Throne – he is still a bastard,
if Lyanna and Rhaegar weren’t married, but
there are theories they could have had a secret
wedding – maybe Bran could have a vision
of that.
Further, as a Targaryen, Jon might be able
to ride dragons like Daenerys.
He might be fireproof like Daenerys – except
there was that one time he got burned – the
whole fireproof thing is confusing in the
show.
But another big thing is that Azor Ahai, the
hero prophesied to save the world from darkness
is apparently meant to be from Aerys’ line
– so Jon now fits another part of this prophecy.
Also, Ned leans Arthur Dayne’s famous sword,
called Dawn, against Lyanna’s bed, which
kind of connects to another part of the Azor
Ahai prophecy, saying he’ll be born beneath
a bleeding star.
Dawn is loosely connected to stars, and it’s
literally covered in blood.
So yeah, basically, more evidence that Jon
is Game of Thrones Jesus.
The real tricky question is how Jon, and the
rest of Westeros, will find out about his
parentage.
Bran could tell Jon, but the rest of Westeros
will want proof before they let him sit the
Iron Throne or whatever.
And there are a few ways this could happen
– maybe Howland Reed, the other survivor
of the Tower of Joy, could turn up.
Maybe there’s some kind of secret hidden
still in the Winterfell crypts.
We’ll have to wait and see.
But at least we now the truth – that Jon
is a son of ice and fire.
At Winterfell, the northern lords declare
Jon the King in the North, the White Wolf,
just as Robb Stark was the Young Wolf.
And this is super cool, though it doesn’t
make much sense.
Like, sure, Jon was brave at the Battle of
the Bastards, but he’s also a deserter of
the Night’s Watch, which is punishable by
death.
And he let wildlings through the Wall, which
most of the north hates.
And he’s a bastard, not the Lord of Winterfell
– Sansa is the rightful ruler.
And half these lords weren’t at the battle,
they’ve never met Jon before – so why
do they all love him and trust him so much?
If Jon becomes King in the North in the books,
it’ll happen a very different way – there’s
this whole thing with Robb naming Jon his
heir, then sending Maege Mormont and Galbart
Glover to Howland Reed so maybe in the books
those guys will turn up and reveal Robb’s
wishes – but it’s probably fair that the
show simplifies this.
The point is that Jon now rules a huge chunk
of Westeros, apparently including the Vale,
cause Littlefinger says he is sworn to House
Stark – but of course we know not to trust
Littlefinger – he wants Sansa, not Jon,
in charge in the north, so we’ll likely
see some conflict between these guys next
season.
Littlefinger may try to turn Sansa against
Jon.
Then Jaime returns to King’s Landing, like
Troy in Community, and this is definitely
the darkest timeline.
Cersei sits the Iron Throne, crowns herself
the ruler of Westeros, while her city still
burns in the background, she’s gone full
Evil Queen here, this is some dark lord shit.
She’s not the rightful ruler, she’s a
dictator, who seized power by blowing up everyone
else – maybe you could call that right of
conquest.
But this is not a stable regime – the people
will hate her – because she just blew up
the equivalent of the Vatican.
She has no allies or army as far as we know.
And the Tyrells, Martells and Targaryens are
allied against her.
So this reign of terror probably won’t last
long.
The interesting drama will be Jaime’s response.
He’ll be having flashbacks to Aerys, the
Mad King he killed to protect the people,
if Jaime is to become the better person he’s
trying to be, maybe he’ll have to kill his
lifelong lover, this terrible new mad queen.
Which, would, by the way, fulfil another part
of this prophecy, that Cersei would be killed
by her valonqar, or little brother.
The episode ends with another much-anticipated
moment – Daenerys Targaryen finally sails
for Westeros, with a huge fleet, full of Unsullied,
and Dothraki, and ironborn, not to mention
three dragons – she’s also got Varys,
and Tyrell and Martells ships, so this must
be months after the rest of the episode cause
of the travel time.
But, sidenote – this is the first time we’ve
seen Varys and Daenerys together, and they
actually have a lot to talk about, cause Varys
has been fucking with Daenerys’ life for
years – his scheming with Illyiro led to
Dany’s marriage with Khal Drogo.
Varys informed on Dany to the small council,
and ordered an assassination attempt on her
once – and Dany does know this, even in
the show, so she should have some tough questions
for the eunuch.
Another little thing is that it’s weird
to see the Dothraki so comfortable at sea,
when it’s kind of a thing that they’re
terrible sailors – maybe that’ll come
up later.
But this is a great way to end the season,
Daenerys is finally set to take the Throne.
So let’s look at the situation at the end
of the season.
On the Iron Throne, you’ve got Cersei Lannister,
with Qyburn and the Mountain at her side.
Jaime’s there too, and he might do something
to stop her.
Allied against her are the Tyrells, under
Olenna, and Dorne, under the Sand Snakes,
who are supporting Daenerys Targaryen, sailing
in from the east with Tyrion and Varys and
Missandei and Grey Worm and Yara and Theon
and an army.
The King of the Iron Islands is Euron Greyjoy,
and he’ll probably be a big bad guy next
season – remember he wants to kill Yara
and Theon, marry Dany and take over the world,
and in the books he has some schemes involving
black magic and dragons.
Jon Snow is the King in the North, supported
by the northern houses and by Tormund’s
wildlings, while Sansa is apparently still
the Lady of Winterfell.
The north is supposedly supported by the Vale,
ruled in name by Robin Arryn, but in practice
by Littlefinger – who’ll probably also
be a big baddie next season.
It’s not clear who rules the riverlands,
now that Walder Frey’s dead, but Edmure
Tully’s still alive, so maybe his power
could eventually restored.
For now you’ve got Beric, Thoros, the Hound,
Brienne, Pod and Arya all travelling round
the riverlands, and Melisandre coming in from
the north so all sorts of stuff could happen
around there.
Down south Sam and Gilly are at Oldtown, and
Randyll and Dickon might come for them.
Over in Essos, Meereen is left to Daario and
the Sons of the Harpy, and presumably Kinvara
and the red priests are still there – kinda
weird they didn’t do much this season.
Jorah is wondering round Essos somewhere,
looking for a cure for his greyscale.
Gendry is still rowing around somewhere as
well, presumably…
We might also see Tycho Nestoris again – remember
the Crown owes the Iron Bank a lot of money.
But of course the biggest threat of all is
posed by the white walkers and their army
of the dead.
Dolorous Edd and the Wall probably can’t
stop them on his own, nor can Benjen, so Bran
and Meera better get south soon.
So the big conflicts next season will probably
be Dany’s invasion against Cersei and maybe
Euron, there’ll be stuff in the north between
Jon and Sansa and Littlefinger, but above
all there’ll be the War for the Dawn, between
the white walkers and everybody else.
There are just two short seasons of Game of
Thrones left, like thirteen hours of content.
This is the beginning of the end.
So Game of Thrones Season 6 is done, but there
is still so much Thrones left to talk about,
with theories, and analysis of characters
and plot, and predictions and speculation
about the future of the series, and heaps
of stuff in the books that doesn't even appear
in the show.
So this is the kind of content you'll be seeing
from Alt Shift X when we return in August
– we’re taking a break for a while – the
Patreon will be paused so no one’ll be charged
for July.
But make sure to subscribe so you don’t
miss future videos – if you’d like to
be notified the moment videos come out, you
can press this bell button on the Alt Shift
X channel on the YouTube app on your phone.
Also, if you haven’t read the books, now
is a really good time to start.
The books are everything you love about the
Game of Thrones show, but more.
More detail more depth, more complexity, more
drama, more politics, more mysteries, more
magic, so many extra little connections and
relationships and backstories and side-characters
and histories – the books are amazing.
They aren't the easiest read – they are
dense and complex and very bloody long, but
if you can get into em, you will really enjoy
em.
So there's a link in the description to buy
the books – its an Amazon link that supports
this channel if you use it at no extra cost
to you, otherwise you can find the books by
other ways online.
If you’ve already read the books and you
wanna go deeper down the rabbit hole, go check
out the Game of Thrones forums, like the Song
of Ice and Fire subreddit, and Westeros.org.
Many of the ideas and theories discussed on
this channel come from these forums.
Also the podcasts – there are heaps of great
Game of Thrones podcasts, two of the biggest
and best are Radio Westeros and History of
Westeros.
Really in-depth analysis of story, themes,
theories, predictions, so go and check them
out.
Between the podcasts and the forums and the
books and this channel, there is plenty of
Thrones content to last until next season
– and if we’re lucky we may even get a
new book soon…
So thank you for watching.
Thank you for commenting and liking and subscribing
and thank you for the emails and tweets and
messages I’m sorry I can’t reply to them
all but the support is really sweet.
Thanks to the caption translators who’ve
been making captions available in dozens of
languages.
And the biggest of thanks goes to the Patrons
on Patreon.
This Season 6 Explained series, doing a video
every week, would have been totally impossible
without your support.
This channel has come a long way from where
it was a year ago thanks to Patrons.
In fact one of the things we’re doing now
is looking for a production assistant to help
make videos faster.
So, if you’re good with After Effects, and
you know Game of Thrones well, and you’re
free for some production work, especially
during Season 7 – please click on the link
to the Google form below to apply.
Shout out to Patrons Jason A. Diegmueller,
Reverend Xandria, @MrFifaSA, Cameron Weiss,
David Howe, @Vineyarddawg, Eric Louis-Dreyfus,
Jason Pan, Alex Kirkendall, Cynbobby Joe,
Kate Lyons, Ryan Steele, Michael Appell, Brandon
L. Staggs, Jason Rattray, Fallon M, Cregg
Riley, Sean Ludtke, Todd Marcus, Chris Cole,
Jake Burling, Chris Amolsch, Matthew Elisha
Williams, Fred Petty, Moiraine Sedai, Kevin
Donohue, Sandeep Rath, XDomas, Terd_Furgeson,
Jori Strack, Neil Ramroop, Ricky Myint, thank
you all for your support.